for me one of the hardest things about
having a friend incarcerated is the fact
that when i want to talk to him i can't
we're so used to being able to just snap
a picture and text it to somebody
we can't share that kind of information
with inmates
[Music]
i am an artist
and i'm also the owner and director of
flip book to llc
[Music]
when you're serving a sentence you miss
out on a lot of the day-to-day
activities
being able to see a clip a video of your
family and friends can make a huge
difference
but we can't share that kind of
information with inmates
the flipbooks i do take your video and
turn it into something tangible that you
can hold
basically four to six seconds worth is
enough to make a nice length of flip
book and when an inmate gets a flip book
they can see a brief moment into the
lives of the people they love
you can say a lot in 30 sheets of flip
book it's it's really cool
i've been incarcerated in state of
colorado for about 13 years
the hardest part of doing time is being
separated from the people you care about
they said they were going to send me a
gift and i didn't know what it was going
to be and i got a sheet of
all these little pictures and then i
understood what it was
this was the first one
it was a little dog playing in the mud
dog joy
pure unadulterated dog joy
it was a treat
to be able to
sort of get a video you know in a way
i think it's easy to understand
why flipbooks can be so powerful for the
inmates
but sometimes i feel like it might
almost be more powerful for the families
involved
being able to take just a few seconds to
capture some video that you know is
going to end up in the hands of the
person you love is a very powerful thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to
so
[Music]
i'm wim krausweg
i collect messages in bottles from the
beach
in 34 years
i collected over 1200 messages in
bottles
i have all the time in the world and
instead of talking with other old people
i love to walk on the beach and see the
surprises
[Music]
[Music]
in 1983 i found three of them so i wrote
them that i was surprised to find these
messages and the other surprise was that
i got answers of all three of them
and that's when i decided okay i'm a
collector of messages in bottles
i find my messages in bottles on the
beach of sandford where i live and on
the dutch islands
messages in bottles is slow mail it
takes you
days weeks or months
to
find a bottle
and i don't even on the beach open them
i put them in my rug pack
and at home i open them to have a second
surprise
this is the german girl the first letter
she wrote me on the 28th of august in
1983.
it pleased me to receive your letter
[Music]
writing is something you can think about
what you're writing when you're talking
with somebody you're interrupted and
getting an answer before you expect it
when you write something you can write
on your own nobody is interrupting you
and when you get an answer i cannot
interrupt them
even when i have been writing only a few
times with somebody i got to know him
and when i'm going through this
collection and i see the message then i
remember how much fun we had for a while
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i just like it when my kids get up and
they're in a good mood and they're all
smiling
that's my bit the first bit of the day
[Music]
family don't cost nothing
it's like your mom's like your best
friend
[Music]
yes um she puts big smile on her face
[Music]
she's 71 she's small but she's lovely
all right cleaning outside it's like
when the weather's really warm i like
looking at trees
[Music]
me and when i make it for me for my
dress is lovely color
and it's
i'm proud feel
i'm happy
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's strangers smiling at strangers
dancing with strangers that's what's
community
the song that the bike makes when he's
arriving at home this makes me very
happy
because
yeah
[Music]
i like having a bacon sandwich on my
balcony
so i haven't been very happy lately
probably
friends because they're always there for
you finding dinosaurs in the fruit bowl
that makes me happy
going different places meeting different
people
and different cultures that gentleman
over there who makes me happy cycling
with my mates playing lego
live music i love pizza puffy
her laugh her life is really really
crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you